[Musique]
pour impacter le monde
il faut d'abord s'impacter et changer
soi-même
et pour s'impacter changer soi-même il
faut avoir la discipline la volonté et
la détermination de changer et de
transformer toute situation de la vie en
opportunité
une seule clé pour ça
attirer et saisir des opportunités c'est
se demander si soi-même on a une
opportunité pour les autres
nous sommes en janvier 2010
je suis en terminale
il est 5 heures du matin
je suis allongé dans mon lit
et je pense comme à mon habitude
donc on pourrait parler de visualisation
aujourd'hui
je pense
et vous savez je me pose une question
qui est assez simple
et qui pourtant pour moi est assez
structurante même si cette question est
aujourd'hui galvaudé
qu'est-ce que j'ai envie de faire de ma
vie qu'est-ce que j'ai envie de faire
demain
je suis encore légèrement endormi
et je sens une ombre bienveillante se
rapprocher
il y a une personne qui est en train
d'arriver
ce n'est pas habituel mais juste serein
parce que le sang de la bienveillance
dans la démarche de cette personne
cette personne rentre dans ma chambre
je suis encore légèrement endormi
et comme par hasard
elle s'assoit à côté de moi sur le lit
il me pose la même question
qu'est-ce que tu as envie de faire après
ton bac
je la regarde toujours légèrement dormi
cette personne et je vois dans ses yeux
une telle volonté une telle envie de me
voir réussir de me voir réaliser un
certain nombre de choses
et je lui réponds avec la plus grande
sincérité
j'ai envie de devenir pilote
j'ai envie d'intégrer la plus grande
académie dans l'aviation aux États-Unis
cette personne ma mère
me regarde
Marc silence
et me répond
aujourd'hui avec une telle lenteur dans
sa voix
il me dit quelque chose qui me
bouleverse assez à ce moment là
nous sommes cette frères et sœurs
et elle nous dit la chose suivante
je vais te laisser
je vais aller au travail
tu vas passer la journée à réfléchir
et le soir quand je vais rentrer
tu me diras
lequel de tes frères et sœurs
nous devons vendre pour avoir les 50 000
dollars nécessaires chaque année pour
tes études de pilote
oui il fallait 50 000 dollars minimum
par an
on n'avait pas 150 000 dollars dépensés
sur le coup j'ai eu un sentiment
d'injustice qui m'a traversé le corps en
me disant je sais que j'ai la capacité
de le faire je sais que je peux aller où
j'ai envie d'aller mais me voilà je vais
être limité par des contraintes
financières
nous sommes nombreux à rencontrer des
personnes comme ça qui sont créatives
qui sont très travailleuses qui sont
pétri talent
mais qui au jour le jour font face en
certain nombre de contraintes et en
général quand le veuille ou pas dans le
monde dans lequel on vit des contraintes
financières
ce jour-là j'ai appris une leçon
qui pour moi et ma façon aujourd'hui
d'impacter le monde
à l'époque elle me l'a dit avec ses
propres mots
parce que j'ai dû me rabattre je suis
des études d'ingénieurs merci lu TT
elle m'a dit
certes c'est pas la voix que tu as envie
de suivre
mais en réalité la plus grande
opportunité qui existe ce n'est pas
celle de se retrouver dans un pays en
particulier
ce n'est pas celle de faire un métier en
la plus grande opportunité
ce n'est pas l'environnement que tu vas
voir
la plus grande opportunité c'est celle
qui en chacun de nous-mêmes
la plus grande opportunité c'est de
conscientiser ce qu'on a
et le transformer en opportunité ou que
tu sois le plus important sera de
composer au mieux avec ce que tu as pour
être ta propre opportunité
et c'est avec cette vision que j'ai
attaqué le monde
c'est avec cette vision que j'ai quitté
le Cameroun et que j'ai démarré mes
études ingénieurs
je suis très très heureux aujourd'hui
parce qu'au final j'ai pu aller aux
États-Unis pour faire un autre master
tu peux m'en sortir et caresser le rêve
qui était le mien
mais ça ne suffisait pas
impacter le monde ne s'arrête pas à ça
j'étais en perpétuel recherche de
quelque chose qui pouvait avoir pour moi
du sens de quelque chose où je pourrais
me dire que je vais laisser vraiment une
trace qui va impacter le monde de
génération en génération qui va
commencer par impacter ma famille qui va
commencer par impacter mon pays qui va
impacter le continent qui va impacter le
monde j'avais envie qu'on se souvienne
de moi j'ai envie qu'on se souvienne de
moi j'ai envie qu'on se souvienne de moi
et à la recherche du diamant j'ai fini
par tomber et j'ai fini par trouver de
l'or
j'ai fait une rencontre en 2017 la
rencontre d'une personne la rencontre
d'une opportunité
j'ai rencontré le monde de la finance
mais d'une autre façon
le monde de la finance qui s'est associé
la dimension humaine et la dimension
financière
aujourd'hui et depuis 2017 je suis
conseiller en création et en gestion de
patrimoine
et j'ai deux casquettes aujourd'hui dans
mon activité qui me tiennent
particulièrement à cœur de par cette
histoire
la première casquette que j'ai
c'est celle
d'accompagner des personnes pour
qu'elles puissent investir pour préparer
leur avenir financier
à quoi ressemblerait le monde si on
avait tous la possibilité si on avait
tous le choix de partir à la retraite ou
pas à 50 ans
chacun d'entre nous sont se pose un
instant la question que serions-nous en
train de faire si le temps l'argent et
la santé n'était pas du tout un problème
pour nous que serions-nous en train de
faire
beaucoup d'entre nous ne seraient pas là
beaucoup d'entre nous feraient plein
d'autres choses
à quoi ressemblerait le monde si tous
nos enfants pouvaient exprimer leurs
talents c'est la seule limite que chacun
d'entre nous pouvait avoir si sa propre
volonté ses propres capacités
travailler et non les contraintes
financières
aujourd'hui c'est mon combat
la deuxième casquette que j'ai c'est de
former d'autres personnes
à se mettre à leur propre compte parce
que oui la difficulté la contrainte ce
n'est pas une fatalité
c'est parfois des opportunités de
croissance c'est parfois une invitation
à aller chercher encore plus au plus
profond de nous parce qu'on est capable
de faire beaucoup plus
je suis heureux de ne pas être un pilote
aujourd'hui
je suis heureux d'avoir eu ces
contraintes
et ma vision aujourd'hui c'est d'aider
aussi d'autres personnes à conscientiser
le fait que des contraintes peuvent être
des opportunités ça peut être des
invitations à aller vraiment chercher
une force qui est cachée en nous pour
pouvoir avoir de l'impact dans ce monde
oui
de l'impact
et quand je regarde en arrière j'ai
envie de dire une seule chose qui est
assez simple
si nous voulons impacter le monde
impactant nous nous-mêmes si nous
voulons impacter le monde impactant
notre environnement
est-ce que toutes les personnes que vous
rencontrez et que vous passez 5 minutes
avec elle sont capables de vous dire ok
ça a été une opportunité dans ma vie de
passer cinq minutes avec toi
parce que nous sommes dans un monde
d'interdépendance
rêver c'est gratuit
j'ai aussi pris à cœur d'impacter le
monde en faisant une chose qui est très
simple de tellement rêver
de tellement oser
de tellement agir
que mon parcours que mes réalisations
que la personne que je vais devenir va
inspirer au rêve
j'ai envie de rappeler aux personnes que
le rêve est gratuit
et quand je me trouve face à une
contrainte aujourd'hui mais je réagis
différemment ce n'est plus le Marcel
couché dans son lit en 2010 c'est une
autre personne je réagis différemment
aujourd'hui quand je suis façonne que je
suis face à une difficulté je me
rappelle que je suis venu pour impacter
le monde je me rappelle que ma simple
action une action simple de ma part peut
avoir un effet papillon peut avoir des
cascades peut avoir des ricochets
qui change le monde
dans ce moment difficile ce que je fais
tout simplement
pour prendre les meilleures décisions
qui soient pour aller chercher le
courage
je fais un voyage
je ferme les yeux
dans ce voyage je vais deux trois quatre
siècles plus tard
je me vois arriver dans un domaine
j'ouvre la porte
et je vois des centaines de personnes
j'observe je vois des personnes qui me
ressemblent
je vois les personnes qui me sourient
et au loin j'aperçois une personne
une jeune personne qui court vers moi
et la cour vers moi
me prend dans ses bras
il me dit merci
merci pour ce que tu as fait
merci pour l'impact que tu as laissé
nous en profitons aujourd'hui
cette personne c'est mon arrière arrière
arrière arrière arrière arrière arrière
petit fils
et à ce moment je reviens de mon voyage
j'ouvre les yeux
et je me pose des questions très simples
pour décider agir et trouver le courage
qu'est-ce que Marcel je dois prendre
comme décision aujourd'hui
pour que dans 10 générations
il y a une personne qui me dise merci
pour ce que tu as fait
quelle est la meilleure décision qui
m'amènerait vers ça
quel est le nombre de familles que tu
auras impacté parce que tu les auras
accompagné d'un point de vue financier
qu'est-ce que tu auras laissé comme
trace
je vais vous faire un autre cadeau
je vais me faire un autre cadeau
cette fois-ci je fais le même voyage
et je me projette dans 10 ans
et c'est moi que je rencontre
c'est le mois dans 10 ans que je
rencontre
et le mois dans 10 ans me dit merci
merci pour qui tu as été il y a 10 ans
merci pour les actions que tu as mené à
10 ans merci pour l'impact que tu as eu
durant cette dix dernières années
et je me repose la question qu'est-ce
que je dois faire aujourd'hui pour avoir
ce même merci dans 10 ans parce que
quand je veux même pas que tu es je vais
impacter le monde quand je vais grandir
personnellement je vais aider mon
entourage à grandir
pour ma part
je rêve aussi d'un moment où tous qui
m'écoutait on va pouvoir se dire merci
mutuellement
on va pouvoir se dire merci parce que
nous avons été des opportunités les uns
pour les autres
parce que faut attirer et saisir des
opportunités le seul moyen le seul moyen
le seul moyen c'est de se demander si on
est une opportunité pour les autres je
vous donne rendez-vous pour vivre ce
moment je vous donne rendez-vous sur la
place des grands hommes merci à tous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]